starting off this hours Green Bay
Wisconsin Virginia's calling i've
virginia how are you I'm good how are
you better than I deserve what's up all
right so I had seen a video of yours
talking about how you don't need a
credit score and just pay cash for what
you want my problem is is that I have
about ten grand in collection most of it
is medical so I'm wondering if I can
just leave the credit alone and just pay
cash for everything
along with obviously my active debt or
how would you go about that you have
active debt in addition to the ten
thousand dollars in medical correct in
question the medicals in collections the
active debt is not in collections and
how much of that do you have there it's
about two thousand good okay and what's
your household income my boyfriend I
together we make about seventy thousand
who has the debt me okay
what do you make I made thirty thousand
years okay alright how old is the ten
thousand dollars in death that's about a
year okay and have you got health
insurance in place now yeah
okay good alright well what I would do
is work to different debts no balls I'd
leave the medical alone it's sitting
there now you're not paying any payments
on it now right no okay and I'd clear
the two thousand first because you are
paying payments on that and let's get
that cleared up as fast as you possibly
can and then with the medical what I
would do is begin to make them some
offers to settle it as you can save some
money you probably can settle this for
twenty five to fifty cents on the dollar
okay
somewhere around 2500 to 5000 dollars
we'll probably clear this and you need
to clear it not because of your credit
score but because they're gonna sue you
okay if you don't pay it and then
they're gonna come take part of your
check and you don't want it you don't
that's chasing you around for the rest
of your life so right plus they actually
extended medical care to you and you owe
the money from a moral standpoint so
what I'm going to do is say hey I'm a
single lady I make thirty thousand
dollars a year
these are all true statements and you
know I haven't you know what's the
largest one of the deaths of the ten
thousand I believe it's okay you call
them up and you go I have to I have two
thousand seven hundred and forty two
dollars saved when you do that's all
I've got
if you'll take that as settlement for
this five thousand I'll give it to you
today Oh we'll take that and then
payments know that one what I said what
I said was I will give you that as
settlement today but it wipes the debt
out well we won't do that well then you
get no money and you begin this
negotiating back and forth back and
forth back and forth and finally you
settle on a number when you sit on a
number of course you have to have the
money to negotiate that so you're gonna
save up that money right and what I do
is clear off the little one first when
you get to the clear off of two thousand
get out of the way but then whatever
your smallest medical debt is clear it
off first what's the little one three
hundred okay yeah so you probably just
pay that one after you get the two
thousand paid just reach over and pay
that one on your budget okay and that
one's done and cuz it's not it's not big
enough to screw around with you know and
then we're gonna go on to the next one
and then we're gonna go on to the next
one as you get to one that's too big
then just offer them fifty cents or
twenty-five cents on the dollar as long
as you have the money to do that
so you have to have saved up the money
to have the conversation you following
this yeah okay then once they once you
go with them and you're gonna go back
and forth for weeks it's not gonna
happen in two phone calls okay that
sounds like fun it's gonna be a blast
but it's gonna save you about five grand
okay that's it's worth it you know not a
bad part-time job is one way of looking
at it and so on it's an ugly part-time
job that's gonna make you five thousand
dollars or so and or you can just save
up and pay for and I don't care if you
want to go the other way
but if you want if you want to argue
with them you can probably get them down
because they you know I'm a single lady
I make $30,000 a year I don't have money
after I buy food this is your pitch okay
when I buy food and lights I don't have
any money left and so if you want some
money I've got some right now and I will
settle this with you now two rules once
you get them to agree to the number and
you have the money in the account before
you do that rule number one is do not
send them any money unless you have this
in writing if it's not in writing it
never happened they will have the
weirdest memory that your conversation
never happened if you do not have it in
writing
you understand me they lie yeah okay so
get it in writing number two once you
settle the deal we'll just take your
checking account information and draft
your checking account oh no no no no no
no no no no because they'll clean out
everything that's in there and then you
won't be able to pay rent or buy your
food or something okay
now you do not give them electronic
access to your main checking account
because they'll clean you out so you can
either do a prepaid Visa card and just
put the exact amount on there and let
them take it out of that and then close
that one and then go get another prepaid
Visa card and do another one or you can
wire them the money or you can go over
there and take them a check you're in
Green Bay it's not that big you know and
just sit there with them and get it in
writing and hand them a check billed and
come awesome yes my credit report or
it'll show it'll show a bad debt which
it is today it's a bad debt that has
been settled and so it will leave a
it'll leave a black mark but I mean a
gray mark but it's not a black mark
today it's a black mark okay you're not
getting anything with bad debt on there
you're not gonna get a house you're not
gonna get anything with your name on it
without standing collections that are
bad debt so you've got to clean them up
just but also just from a practical
standpoint they're just gonna bug the
crud out of you for the rest of your
life and you just you need to clean it
up so get yourself on a real tight
budget and start working it through
let's get the rid of tooth
another active debt then pay off the
$300 one and then let's start the
process of negotiating with the rest of
the nine thousand seven hundred dollars
worth or so of which five thousand
dollars is one of them save up a little
settle in writing no electronic access
to your checking account save up a
little settle in writing no electronic
access to your checking account and you
just work your way down that list of
those old bad debts and that's the best
way to work through it